bell heterogeneity is always present to
some extent within any cell population
be it cell type or function where a cell
is in its cell cycle
as well as differences at the
biochemical or genetic level
seemingly identical cells can differ
greatly in their response to changes in
environment
and these differences can have important
consequences for both health
and function of the entire population
importantly we should be aware that
disease states such as cancer
are highly heterogeneous which goes some
way to explaining why there is such a
diverse range of pharmacological
responses to therapeutics
in cancer treatment being able to
analyze at a cell by cell level
allows for the study and identification
of subpopulations
that could potentially be overlooked
within population average day
analysis so what are the current
techniques used for the analysis of
cellular subsets
and what kind of biological insight and
productivity do they provide
flow cytometry has the ability to take
large numbers of cells
and coupled with the use of fluorescence
separate cells
by getting into particular subsets
depending on their marker expression
as well as size and complexity and this
technique is becoming ever more high
throughput
with the help of platforms such as the
iq screener
however because flow requires the
lifting of cells
in order to put them through the machine
it doesn't take into account the
morphology of the cells
in order to do this you need microscopy
high content imaging uses automated
microscopy
and image processing allows for high
throughput screening which can again be
used for subset identification depending
on morphology and fluorescence
however this uses end point fixed and
stain methods
so it doesn't afford the user any sense
of kinetic data
time-lapse microscopy is able to provide
kinetic data
and can be used to monitor cells
label-free using a specially designed
microscope stage
however this is mainly single cells
being tracked over time
and so cell sampling sizes are small and
throughput is
low these are all powerful methods for
studying the subject of heterogeneity
however there remains an
unmet need for a technology which
provides high-throughput
in-depth lifestyle imaging that is truly
kinetic
inkysite provides a novel integrated
solution for real-time
automated image collection and the
analysis of cell biology
it is a well-established method for
quantifying phenotypic changes in cells
it's able to do this as the inkocyte
sits in a standard cell incubator
so the user is able to fully control the
cell's environment
whilst automatically capturing and
analyzing time-lapse images
there are a wide range of assays for
quantifying phenotypic changes including
cell proliferation
apoptosis and immune cell killing to
name a few
so far incusite analysis of these assays
has been based on population average
data whereby
information from all objects or cells in
the field of view is consolidated into
an aggregate metric
while this type of analysis is a
powerful tool and such measurements can
accurately capture a population state
and any variation in it
it fails to differentiate a large effect
on small subsets
in the greater population changes in
these small subsets
are masked by the greater number of
cells in the so-called non-reactive
populations
the main content of this webinar is to
introduce our new software
which is capable of analyzing at the
cell by cell level
and we believe this development is an
important addition to the analysis
technologies previously described
so i'm going to first explain how you
would set up an assay
and then how you would go on to analyze
it using the cell by cell analysis
the preparation of the assay plates is
performed as usual
where you would seed yourselves add
treatments and include any
non-perturbing agents
then place in the inky site for image
acquisition and this acquisition step is
all done using the
20 times objective once you have
acquired your images you can then set up
a cell by cell analysis processing
definition
currently this software is optimized for
non-adherent cells only
the analysis allows for the segmentation
of the phase image and subsequently
identifies the cell boundaries and with
this first part of the analysis you
acquire your total cell number metrics
now you have identified your objects you
can then measure and classify them based
on metrics such as
size shape or fluorescence properties
you can see from step 4 that the gating
tool uses a similar concept to flow with
the 2d dot plot
once you have applied your gates you can
then visualize your data
in the form of time courses where you
can observe how your chosen subset
changes over time
so this video nicely puts together the
process of the last couple of stages
that have just been described
the assay set up here uses red labeled
cells in the presence of a cytotoxic
agent and our caspase-3 reagent has been
added which lights dead cells of green
so here we have the 2d plot where our
cells or events
are represented by these dots on the
graph and we have
red fluorescence signal on the x axis
and green on the y
a quadrant gate has been applied to the
plot where the bottom right square shows
events with a positive red signal
representing all of the living cells and
the upper left
showing cells positive for a green
signal when they're dead
over time you can see the cell
population moving through the quadrants
starting where the majority of cells are
just positive for a red signal
but then as the cytotoxic agent starts
to kill the cells
the population moves into the upper
right quadrant where cells are in the
process of dying
and so are both red and green and then
finally into green when they are no
longer alive
and are not able to produce the red
fluorescent protein
from this population gating the
information can then be used to produce
time courses of your data's behavior
with the added advantage of being able
to see your gating applied to the images
which you can see here on the far right
this gating or back gating feature
allows you to color code your subsets
and overlay this gating back onto the
original images
so you can also observe how your
subpopulations are interacting with each
other
now i'm going to go through some
validation data for the cell by cell
analysis
as well as some examples of how you
could use this capability
we validated the phase segmentation by
comparing
cell count acquired by cell by cell
analysis to nuclear count
the cells here in used in these images
on the left hand side
are your cat nut like red cells and they
have been plated at various densities
and then monitored and analyzed over a
four day period
each image was analyzed using cell by
cell analysis
which is here in the top right image
with the mask applied in yellow
and the same image was analyzed using
nuclear counting which is shown in the
bottom right hand image
where the mask is applied in green
in the far right panel the data from
each analysis method
is shown on the graph with phase count
represented by closed circles and
nuclear count
or nook red by open circles as you can
see
each dataset is highly comparable and
overlays the other almost exactly
for all of the cell densities and for
the entirety of the experiment
this result was also achieved using a
number of different non-deterrent cell
lines
the ability to use a label-free method
of cell counting really does benefit the
user greatly
and allows for truly uncompromised live
cell assays
this next slide is validation for the
use of cell by cell analysis itself
and outlines the advantages it provides
the user
so still using solely the phase masking
abilities that have been afforded by the
new phase segmentation algorithm
we can already extract a great amount of
data which includes information on a
cell's morphology
the image on the left shows activated
pbmcs
that have been individually segmented by
the new software
and this enables the user to measure
size using area
and shape using eccentricity
eccentricity refers to roundness of a
cell
where an increase in the arbitrary unit
means the cell is becoming more
elongated
the two graphs here show how the data
looks when the these values are
presented as an average
the control population is non-activated
pvmcs
which are shown in grey and activated in
blue
the graph on the left describes an
increase in the eccentricity of
activated cells
and the graph on the right shows there
is also
an increase in size both of which are
hallmarks of activation
looking at just these two graphs you
could assume that by the final time
point
the activated cells were a homogeneous
population that have all become large
and elongated
however the true power of using cell by
cell analysis
is being able to look at the
distribution of the data the images
along the top
show the difference between the
non-activated and activated population
over the course of the experiment and we
can see in the image on the right there
is a clear increase
in heterogeneity within the population
in regards
to cell size and shape when you plot all
of these cells as individual events
below
on the 2d plots these differences become
even more apparent
at the start of the experiment we can
see a very homogeneous population
post activation we do see the large and
elongated cell subset
as described in the previous slide
however
it is very obvious that there are a
great deal of other cells that do not
fall into this category
and we can see using cell by cell
analysis the total population is
actually highly heterogeneous
only with cell by sun analysis is the
user able to view this data in deeper
biological detail
now aside from differences in morphology
pbmcs themselves are made up of a host
of various different immune cells
and using phase alone they cannot be
distinguished from each other
for further subset identification
fluorescence must be used
we have a method for fluorescently
labeling cell surface cd markers on live
cells
using our fab floor 488 antibody
labeling kit
the antibody raised against the
particular mark of interest is firstly
mixed with our fab
floor 488 reagent which fluorescently
labels
said antibody the fab is raised against
the sc
portion of the antibody so the labeled
antibody is still able to function and
bind to the marker
the labelled antibody is then added to
the assay plate together
with the fluorescence background
suppressor and any other reagents
necessary for the assay
lastly the cells are added to the plate
and then the assay plate is placed in
the inkocytes for imaging
the antibody is then able to bind to the
marker as and when it appears on the
cell
allowing for the identification of
further subsets
and this is a one step no wash or
separation protocol
and it's non-perturbing and compatible
with incucite optics
this is an example of some cell staining
using the protocol just described
the left panel shows the phase image of
ramos cells
and in the middle image we see them
fluorescently labeled with the cd20
antibody
together with the fab floor reagent the
right image
shows the phase cell by cell mask
overlay and the fluorescence properties
inside this mask
are added as a metric that can be used
for gating
this graph shows the number of ramos
cells positive for different markers as
a percentage of the total population
including cd45 and a control igg to
exemplify
that this labeling is both specific and
long-lasting
this next slide further validates the
ability to detect subsets
using fluorescent markers here we use
mixed populations of urcat
and ramos cells and labeled with a cd20
antibody
cd20 is a b cell marker and is only
expressed on the ramos cells
the images on the far left show a 50 50
mix of the two cell lines labeled with
cd20
you can see the above image shows
roughly 50 of the cells are labeled
and the image below has the background
applied where the pink outline
represents cells that are positive for
cd20
and the blue lines highlight cells that
are negative
the middle panel expresses the cd20
positive population
as a percentage of the total population
which corresponds to the original
percentages of ramos cells added to the
mixes
cd45 which is present on both cell types
was therefore represented by 100 of the
population regardless of cell type or
proportion
the panel on the right shows how the
cd20 positive population
can be tracked over time and the
proportions also remain the same
just to note that there is an increase
seen in the actual percentage over time
in each of the mixed cultures and this
is purely because the ramos cell line
has a more rapid rate of proliferation
conversely
the negative population could also be
identified and graphed
in order to describe the urcat
population
we can also take this example further
using two colours
this is a game using mixed populations
of immortalized felines
these being eurkats which are a t cell
cancer cell line
and thp1 cells which are a leukemic
monocyte cell line
here in the upper left image we have
identified the cd3 expressing cells
which are the urcats
and these are green and outlined in blue
and the negative population outlined in
yellow
an exon 5 red has also been added which
identifies dead or dying cells
which you can see in the image to the
right to these mixed populations we
added fast ligand which specifically
kills t
lymphocytes the bottom two panels show
how the dot plots are used to separate
the dyncat sub population
which are cv3 positive and a nexin
positive
in the graph on the right the numbers of
dynacap express as a percentage of the
total population
are proportional to the known
percentages that were added to the thp1
cells at the beginning of the assay
it is also important to show that this
method of measuring protein expression
is comparable to technology that already
exists
and so increasing data was compared head
to head with that of flow cytometry
pbmcs were isolated from a number of
different donors
as shown in the table on the right and
immunophenotype
using either the inkyocite subfloor
reagent coupled with incubicide imaging
and analysis
or flow cytometer using the standard
antibodies and protocols
it can be clearly seen from the graph on
the left the numbers between these two
techniques marry up nicely
and show a strong correlation between
the two methods
now we can return to what was previously
discussed in regards
to the heterogeneity of activated pbmcs
and focus on further analysis
using both morphology and fluorescence
fab floss 488 labeled cd71 has been
added to this activation
upregulation of cd71 expression on cd8
positive t
cells is an early marker for their
activation cell area and green
fluorescence
have been used to construct 2d plots as
shown on the left
at 0 hours the majority of the
population is again very
homogeneous where cells are small and do
not express cd71
after 120 hours we see the population
becomes very heterogeneous in both size
and marker expression the middle graph
shows the overall expression of cd71 is
increasing as a percentage
of the total population and the
activation
appears to cause upregulation to cd71
specifically
if we use cd4 as another example this
marker increase is significantly smaller
the graph on the far right then shows
this expression in more detail
and shows that it is the largest cells
that are preferentially expressing the
cd71 rather than the smaller pbmcs
so by using the power of cell by cell
analysis we can identify individual
subpopulations that are responsible for
the increases in various marker
expression
and track this subset over time we can
also use marker expression to show how
sub-populations
respond to biological stimuli in
different ways
and also track these changes in subsets
over time and importantly
link this to function the images on the
left
show pbmcs activated with interleukin-2
and anti-cd3 antibody
the top image shows cd8 positive t cells
and the image underneath cd4 positive t
cells
both highlighted in pink by the back
gating tool
the graph on the left shows the cell
count in response
to increasing concentrations of anti-cd3
antibody
proliferation in response to activation
with anti-cd3 antibody
shows total phone numbers increase in a
concentration dependent manner
the histogram on the right showing green
fluorescence intensity at 120 hours
gives an indication however that each
cell type is behaving differently
as it is clear that the positive signal
for cd8
is greater in comparison to the cd4
signal
if we then look in more detail at the
data using cell by sun analysis
we can then show the percentage
increases in both cd4
cd8 in the left panel and cd4 in the
middle panel
the graph on the left describes how cd8
positive cells are much more responsive
to treatment with cd3 antibody
at the beginning of the experiment both
cd8 and cd4 positive cells
account for approximately 20 percent of
the total population
there then remains a lag period of
approximately three days
and post this we see an enrichment of
the cd8 cells to over 60 percent
the graph in the middle shows cd4
cells do respond to the cd3 stimulation
and there is a similar temporal pattern
however the result is much less
with only 40 percent enrichment we can
extrapolate this data to suggest that
increase in total cell
proliferation as seen in the previous
slide is mainly due to the cd8 cells
as well as inducing cd8 proliferation
stimulation with cd3
also causes the cells to become
activated where they will seek out and
destroy antigens
using the same stimulation conditions in
an immune cell killing assay
the graph on the right shows that target
cell death aligns temporally with the
cd8 proliferation data
which suggests the enrichment of the cd8
subpopulation
serves to attack and kill any target
cells present
this film on the far right shows cd8
labelled cells
interacting with satellite labeled
sculp3 cells
which are a cancer cell line once the
cd8 cells
have detected the target cell the t cell
then creates an immunological synapse
between the two cells
using the poor forming protein perforin
this then allows it to pump
apoptosis-inducing proteins
into the target cell in order to induce
death
this example shows how incusi technology
can be used to identify and monitor
change in a specific sub-population
and then link this to a functional
output so in conclusion
incusite cell by cell analysis provides
an integrated solution for identifying
and quantifying subsets of living cells
in heterogeneous cultures over time the
module
enables temporal analysis of cell
subsets based on morphology
biomarkers health and function the assay
setup does not require cell lifting
fixing or staining and the simple
experimental analysis workflows are
amenable to the everyday user
this module provides a further dimension
to lifestyle analysis
for non-adherent cells where the user
may answer biological questions at the
cell by cell level